okay so extraction two is now out on
Netflix and the Chris Hemsworth action
film has a lot in it we need to talk
about the film is one of the best
one-shell action take scenes I've seen
in a film and in it we follow the
characters as they blast their way
through a prison have an incredible car
chase in the woods and then shoot it out
on a train whilst enemies try and
surround them it's balls to the wall and
the ending also leaves things off with a
lot of possibilities for the future
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down what happens in it what
could happen next time and also giving
our thoughts on the film as a whole
please hit the Thumbs Up Button if you
enjoy the video and don't forget to
subscribe for breakdowns like this every
day without the way huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into
extraction 2.
so the first film ended with a tease
that Tyler was alive in it we watched
Shelby practicing holding his breath
underwater and a blurry figure could be
seen lurking directly at him that
doesn't happen in this film we don't get
it cleared up but with that being said
eight months later they might bring it
back around at some point however we do
see how Tyler survived the events of the
first film and that he was fixed up in
hospital before getting given a new home
Gary's approached by a mysterious man
who we know from the cast lists called
Alcott and he's played by none other
than Idris Elba informing him that his
ex-wife's sister needs rescuing from
their gangster husband David Tyler sets
out to save the family and take down the
mob now the plot is pretty
straightforward with this being more
about the over-the-top action scenes
that you can't take your eyes off I've
always loved one shot takes and to see
what could basically be three major set
pieces combined into one really elevates
this movie I think what works best about
the scenes like this is that because we
don't cut away we very much feel like
we're part of the action too when is
this Relentless you can almost feel
yourself getting exhausted along with
the characters and when it's over you
even breathe a side relief yourself at
least I I do anyway and if you're here
without seeing the movie then I'd
definitely recommend that you go and
watch it to experience what I'm talking
about and Tyler kills David at the
prison and his brother ends up setting
out on a vendetta against him Tyler also
learns that his wife Mia was actually
behind hiring him and the tour of course
still torn up over the loss of their son
Tyler regrets leaving the pair before he
passed away and he's haunted by the idea
that his son thinks he abandoned them in
order to go and do work to Tyler his son
some walking out the door which he
thinks means that he left him to die
however Mia later explains that what he
actually saw was his dad going off to
help people and his final thoughts of
him would be that he was a brave man
stuff like this really helps to
recontextualize the character and this
movie is sort of about saving the son of
someone else this is seen in Sandra who
ends up reaching out to his uncle zarab
and Tyler sets out to help bring him
back asandro gives up the location of
the family and runs off with surab which
causes things to culminate in an
Austrian church with help from Nick
Drake manages to kill zurab and he saves
Sandro but they're not out of the woods
yet though Caravan and her family are
put into witness protection reik and
Nick are put into prison but that's not
where things end offered somewhat of a
get out of jail free card rake and Nick
attempted with jobs working for Naughty
[__]
11. now who this could be we don't know
but this does at least let us know we're
getting more from the extraction
Universe I can't see them bringing in a
big name actor for it and to be honest I
didn't even expect Idris to show up in
this the Russo Brothers of course have a
lot of pull in Hollywood these days and
in case you don't know the movies are
based off the graphic novels you'd add
prob definitely pronouncing that wrong
key you dad I don't know I'm sorry
because I am a [__] but this graphic
novel was written by the Russo Brothers
along with Andre Park build in geography
as well just point that out now the
film's sort of loosely pulled from it
and in case you don't know it followed
Tyler as he attempted to save the
daughter of an imprisoned mobster named
Eva roach held hostage in Paraguay he
had to break her out of the city and
this played out much like the events of
the first film that changed Eva to Obi
and then the prison scene sort of came
across here with either them being
adapted into Mia's sister Tyler and that
was also American but Chris gets to play
Australian which you know what it's nice
to see him actually doing it for once
now the graphic novel doesn't really
tell us where things are going to go in
the the future but I would love to see
Eva herself become a character in the
third film who kind of bring things full
circle and be a great way to close out
this Trilogy by going back to Idris he
of course featured in the MCU and he
starred alongside Chris in the Thor
films the Russo Brothers directed
Infinity War and the opening of that had
Thor and heindel's final farewell with
both Chris and Idris because of this and
I might be reaching but I'd love to see
the gnarly dude their reference being
played by Tom Hiddleston now Idris of
course is from England and with
Hiddleston being there too you can kind
of imagine how the pair would get to
know each other Hiddleston hiring Idris
to then work with Chris would be such a
cool little meta thing and we've seen
our comic book movie stars have done
stuff together on Netflix so yeah
getting the russos involved there as
well I think it would just work really
well but obviously Reagan Nick don't
know what they're getting themselves
into now as were my thoughts on the
movie I really enjoyed it and like I
said that one shot thing was absolutely
amazing but I did feel that the first
half kind of bogged the movie down and I
actually checked the time when they got
to the bridge prison and that was about
30 minutes in the opening definitely
could have been cut down as I feel the
hot and slower scenes had started things
off didn't add that much for me you can
completely disagree but I think when
you're making a movie that's meant to be
an adrenaline rush it's best to start
things off in a high and then get to the
action as quickly as possible now saying
that Hemsworth is really showing his
capabilities here and the fact that he
puts everything into his roles if you've
seen his show on Disney plus then you'll
know the guy could become the next Tom
Cruise as he does a lot of death-defying
stunts and over the top things man will
like dangle over a 50-foot gorge in
walkout on skyscrapers I'd love to see
him bring more stuff like this to the
movies now the side characters and
family stuff does sort of bog down the
film as I don't really feel like they
get fully fleshed out and I didn't
connect to them that much I would have
even taken flashback scenes with Tyler
and his son to flash out the pain he and
me have felt but that's mainly just
spoken about whereas they get the focus
I think that in these types of movies
the side characters aren't the important
thing though as it's a main only the set
pieces that you end up caring about
however I don't really feel like there's
many people here knocking out the park
acting wise and thus the scenes with
them or you can kind of take them or
leave them it's the same for the plot in
general as it is very predictable and by
the Numbers however like I said where
this movie really strives is during its
action scenes a second to none and up
there with theatrically released movies
so I'm surprised they keep opting just
to send these straight to streaming when
you could definitely tout this as a big
IMAX event if your marketed it properly
so yeah I think you kind of know what
you're coming into with these films and
hey you know it sounds like I'm slagging
them off but I'm not mad at them I
promise actually movies in general can
often be criticized for their plots but
when you can see how much effort they
put into the film it's hard to ding it
for it so overall I I might not have
sounded like it but I had a lot of fun
with extraction too and was pretty grip
when the movie was doing what it does
best I don't think it's going to be
winning any Oscars well it might too far
action but as far as giving me an
enjoyable two hours it definitely
succeeded I'm also very excited to see
where things go in the future with
extraction 3 so it's done its job of
getting me more invested in this
franchise in the end extraction 2 was
great and it scores a six for the plot
but a nine for the action so averaging
that out I think it's about a 7.5 out of
10 but depending on what sort of movie
you're into this is gonna either improve
it or reduce the score in your eyes
anyway let me know your thoughts in the
comment section below and if you want to
support the channel for as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below there's a thank you you'll
get early access to videos every week
you also have our merch store over at
xeroedition.com which sells lots of
nerdy and spy t-shirts hats and more who
just launched a secret Invasion slash
Pulp Fiction and spy t-shirt so if you
want to head over there and help us out
then the links in the description if you
want something else to watch and you're
sticking on Netflix and we've got a
breakdown of Black Mirror On Screen
right now season six has just dropped
we've got lots of things to talk about
and hopefully I see over there right
after this but out of the way huge thank
you for seeing through the video I've
been your host Paul nice see you next
time take care peace
[Music]